- Good morning Believe Nation
today's message is experiment.
Over to you Bob Ross.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Hardly nothing will teach you more
than just experimenting.
Do as many different things
as you have the nerve to do.
Sure just go for it, there.
Sometimes you learn more from mistakes
than you do from trying so hard.
So any time you make a
mistake, before you get upset
with it, look at it.
Sometimes those mistakes those mistakes
turn out to be the best
learning devices we have.
There we are.
I mentioned on one of the other shows,
maybe even a different
series I don't remember,
I get letters from people
who say they're just not
satisfied with what they're doing,
that their painting is
just, they're just not
coming out the way they wanted.
I think if there's a
secret to human nature
it's the fact that we aren't satisfied.
We're never satisfied,
I hope you're absolutely
plagued with dissatisfaction
through your whole life.
Because if you are, you'll
always strive to do better.
And over and over I tell my students
if you ever do a painting you're
completely satisfied with,
you might as well quit.
'Cause you have nowhere else to go.
- If you stop experimenting your business
that's when it's going to fail.
If you just stay in the safe
zone of what has always worked
and you stopped trying new things out,
your business is going to fail.
If you look at anybody
who's had tremendous success
in their life, in their
career, as an entrepreneur,
you'll find that the people
who have the most success
are the ones who experiment the most too.
They try more stuff, they
fail at a lot more stuff,
and they eventually hit
on things that work.
This is why I tell you guys
that you need to be prolific.
And that whatever you are doing,
whatever you want to learn,
you need to be prolific at it to practice,
to experiment, to get better, to fail,
to learn how to add more value.
If you're doing something once a week,
then you're not going to
really get good at it quickly.
If you want to learn a language,
you want to pick up a new skill,
doing that once a week is
not going to be enough.
You'll slowly incrementally
get better at it probably
but if it's important to you,
if this is a really important
goal for you then you need to be prolific.
You want to learn marketing,
that's a thing that
you really want to do,
marketing's going to be really
important to your company,
you have a passion for it,
you need to immerse yourself into it.
You need to practice,
you need to be prolific,
you need to try a whole
bunch of different things,
you need to experiment and
you'll get really good at it.
But if you're not creating enough,
if you're not doing enough tests,
if you're not trying enough,
you're not going to get good at it,
you're just going to be
mediocre and slowly start
getting better and better and better.
And so if it's important for you,
then you need to practice
and you need to experiment.
I would also encourage
you not to worry so much
about getting the perfect thing out.
Perfectionism stops you from
making any kind of progress.
It's holding you where you are.
The attempt to try and
make the perfect thing
is an unattainable goal,
it will never be perfect.
It will always be better.
There's always a way
to make things better.
It's never perfect.
Making this video is not perfect.
As much as I've done 4,000 videos
that have led me to this point
to make this video for you guys,
I could still get way better.
The Evan from 2020 is going
to look back on this video
and say man, I was so
bad, what a bad video.
Look at what I was doing,
look at how I was acting,
look at what I was saying,
I'm so much better now.
I can't believe that video is up.
And that's fine.
Because when you are prolific
in your content creation
or whatever you're trying to do.
When you're creating so much
and you continue to practice,
the one video that you
make doesn't matter.
If I'm trying to practice
learning Italian,
the one conversation I have
with somebody doesn't matter.
It's part of a bigger picture,
it's part of my entire growth.
The individual piece that you're creating,
you're investing time,
you're investing energy,
you're investing your heart, you're trying
to make it the best that you can make it
with the skills and resources
that you have right now.
That's it.
That's the most important thing.
I realized that tomorrow's
going to be a little bit better
and the next day a little bit better.
If you continue to hustle,
then in 12, 24, 36 months,
you're going to be way better.
And then you're still going to drive,
you're going to still continue,
there is no end point.
You want to continue to get better
because this is an important goal for you.
And you do it by continuing to experiment.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious what new
experiment are you going
to try today in your business or your life
that you've been putting off,
you're a little bit scared of,
you feel you may not be good
enough, or ready for it yet,
how can you start it,
some small experiment,
leave it down in the
comments below, super curious
to find out what that is
and by sharing it publicly
hopefully that gives you the push
to actually go and do it.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Raphael Moore.
Raphael thank you so much
for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word,
it really really really means
a lot to me and I hope you're enjoying it.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Hey Believe Nation
for those of you looking
for a little more
inspiration to experiment,
here are some bonus clips
that I think you'll enjoy.
- I don't make notes, I don't,
I react very instinctively
to everything, I'm a great believer
in traveling a great deal.
I don't believe meetings,
more than two people
in a meeting is too
many, really it's true.
Do you know about stand-ups?
No okay, so in Silicon Valley
now, when you have a meeting
everyone stands in a circle
like they're meditating
and that's how, maybe I should try that.
I think that the more you
go out, the more you see,
the more you experience
life, the more you bring back
to your day job so as I was
trying to say in my remarks,
I think the problem about big corporations
is you get a lot of people
my age trying to hold on
to their jobs and you know,
clinging onto their pensions
and their retirement and they're
not experiencing new things
and they don't like change
and they don't like disruption
so they're, either they
don't make a decision
or they say no and as
a result they stagnate.
So it's terribly important
to bring people in
from the outside and not
to remain too insular.
And also to hire as
many young bright people
like all of you as you
can just to teach you
how to think about things
completely differently.
- I think the secret to
my career is I don't know
what I can't do.
So, you know, there were
times when I should probably
sit and think, do I really
want to jump out there
with Phillip Seymour, I
mean with John C. Reilly
and sing The Night Chicago
Died or do I really want
to play the blues with
Little Ed and you know,
you just do it, you just do these things.
- [Charlie] And you
become, the audience wants
you to do these things.
- Yeah I think what's,
I don't know what it is,
but I think over the years
people have gotten comfortable
with the notion that I try things.
- It's almost krypton-esque.
- And they're not worried about me.
Do you know what I mean?
I think that's the key.
People aren't worried
about me getting hurt
because I can you know,
I'll give it 100 percent
and then if it completely
falls on its face,
I'll laugh about it and move on.
And I think there's a
little bit of a sense
after all these years,
people say you know,
alright he tried it, maybe it
worked, maybe it didn't work,
but he had a good time.
- And for you, you can
come back the next night
and the next night and the next night.
- Yeah, I mean that's
you know, I don't know,
over the years I've realized
there are a lot of comedians
that are very worried about
keeping their dignity intact.
- [Charlie] Yeah.
- And keeping their personal space
and keeping their sense of authority.
And for better or worse,
and it might be worse,
I don't have that, you know what I mean?
I'm not, the people that
I've always liked growing up
and I'm not just talking
about late night comedians,
I'm talking about anybody
in movies, in film,
and the people I liked Peter Sellers--
- [Charlie] They would
let it all hang out.
- He'd just go, if you
look at a lot of those old
classic Carson clips,
he's jumping into hot tubs
with Don Rickles.
- [Charlie] Right.
- He's jumping through fake
walls, he's falling on his ass,
he's dressed as Floyd Turbo.
And sometimes I look back
to that and I remember
well, Johnny just went for
it, so for better or worse,
I'll try, I'll get out
there and I'm very physical
and my wife is always
horrified, I'm always coming out
of the shower just covered in bruises
and she'll say, what was that?
And I'll say oh, I did a
bit, we had Jeff Garland
on the show and he and I
rolled down a flight a steps
and I hit a fire hydrant.